[موسيقى]
عاد اليوم الى الواجهه من جديد سيف العدل
وهو الاسم الحربي للجنرال العسكري في
تنظيم القاعده محمد صلاح الدين زيدان ابن
محافظه المنوفيه المصريه
بعد تاكيد الخارجيه الامريكيه لتقرير
الامم المتحده الذي ذكر ان المصري المقيم
في ايران سيف العدل صار زعيما لتنظيم
القاعده وقال متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان تقييمنا يتوافق مع تقييم
الامم المتحده ان الزعيم الفعلي الجديد
للقاعده سيف العدل موجود في ايران الا ان
تنظيم القاعده لم يعلنه رسميا بعد اميرا
له ورد وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسب ما
نقلت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه ايرنا
انصحوا البيت الابيض بوقف اللعبه
رهاب ايران الفاشله
موضحا ان ربط القاعده بايران سخيف ولا
اساس له من الصحه وقال وزير الخارجيه
الايراني مخاطبا مسؤوليه البيت الابيض لا
تعطوا العنوان الخطا وبحسب معلومات
الاستخبارات الامريكيه فقد ظل سيف العدل
فاعلا في تنظيم القاعده على الرغم مما
يروجه عناصر التنظيم من قصه تقييد حريتهم
في مرافق الاحتجاز الايرانيه حيث كان سيف
العدل يرسل مقالاته الى المجلات والمواقع
الجهاديه بدءا من العدد الاول لمجله
البتار لتنظيم القاعده الصادر في العام
2003 ومجله صوت الجهاد حيث التزم بكتابه
عمود ثابت حول الامن والاستخبارات وصولا
الى توجيهاته العسكريه والامنيه في سلسله
مقالات ما بين 2011 و 2015
مرتبطه بما عرف بثورات الربيع العربي في
ليبيا واليمن ومن ثروه تونس فمن هو سيف
العدل او المدني او عابر سبيل صهر اسامه
بن لادن وهل العنوان الوطني الذي قدمته
الولايات المتحده خاطئ حقا ام قديم ام شيء
اخر وما حقيقه علاقته بعماد مغنيه وفيلق
القدس الايراني وما طبيعه علاقته بايمن
الظواهري وهل كان عضوا خاملا في ايران ام
نشطا متحركا من والى خارج ايران انا هدى
الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعات اليوم نفتح ملف
سيف العدل وعلاقته بايران مع ضيف مهم وهو
اللواء الدكتور محسن الفحام نائب رئيس
جهاز مباحث امني الدوله المصريه سابقا
الذي باشر عن قرب تفاصيل ودهاليز شبكات
تنظيم القاعده وغيرها من الجماعات
الاسلاميه الاصوليه وشبكاتها الخارجيه
حياك الله معنا سعاده اللواء اهلا وسهلا
ابغى ابدع حديثنا بهذا السؤال من هو سيف
العدل بحسب ما هو موجود باوراق الامن
المصري شوف العقله هو المصري صلاح الدين
محمد زيدان مواليد محافظه المنوفيه سنه
1960 تعرض الجيش المصري وظهرت عليه علامات
العنف والتطرف
فتم فصله من الجيش المصري في السلاح
المظلات ثم الزمالك اعتقل نظرا لرشده من
خلال او من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه المصريه
سنه
1987 بتهمه محاوله احياء تنظيم الجهاز
وايضا محاوله اغتيال السيد اللواء حسن ابو
باشا وزير الداخليه الاسبق سنه 1989 تم
اخراج عنه لعدم ثبوت الادله وكان معاه
مجموعه من الاخوه برضو اللي هم الجهاديين
تم الاسراج عن البعض منهم
نتيجه عدم توفر الادله في اعقاب الافراج
عنه تمكن من السفر الى افغانستان سافر الى
افغانستان
وانضم لتنظيم الجهاز برضو احنا لغايه ما
دخلناش القاعده الى ان ارتبط ببنت المصري
ابو الوليد
تزوجها وعايش هناك في افغانستان وانجب
منها اربع اولاد ثم بعد ذلك بدا يدرب بعض
ما سمي بالمجاهدين الادغام ضد الاحتلال او
الغزو السوفيتي لافغانستان
ونجح فعلا في تدريب العديد من الكبد اللي
موجوده هناك نتيجه خبرته العسكريه ثم بعد
ذلك توجه الى السودان وفي السودان ايضا
قام بتدريب في الفتره دي
يعني
الحقوا بتنظيم القاعده
وكان الحقيقه نظرا للالتزام ابو الوليد
المصري
والحق بتنظيم القاعده ايوه
القاعده نتيجه انه يعني انه الوليد المصري
كان قريب من
الارهابي اسامه بن لادن ثم بعد ذلك اللي
هو اللي كان ماسك طبعا امين التنظيم يعني
تواجه بعد ذلك الى السودان وبرضه جرب
مجموعه كبيره من
انضموا الى تنظيم القاعده والحقيقه كانت
موجوده في الفتره دي
توازي مع رفعتين مهمين جدا الا وهما تفجير
السفاره الامريكيه في نيروبي وفي دار
السلام
السلطات الامريكيه بدات بقى ترصد المكافات
لضبطه وبدا من هذا التاريخ ان هو يبقى تحت
الملاحقات
الامنيه من الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه
الانتخابيه
هو ايش كانت رتبته لما ترك الجيش مش ترك
الجيش
والتشدد في عمله مع المرؤوسين
لما توجه الى ايران برده الحقيقه
متى بدات مرحلته مع ايران بالضبط بعد
موضوع تفجير السفيراتين راح او تمكن من
التوجه الى افغانستان
وكان برضو من ضمن الناس اللي متهمين
بالتخطيط لتغيير مركز التجاره العالمي في
سبتمبر 2001 عشان افغانستان ترفع الحرج عن
نفسها
حصل نوع من انواع التنسيق ما بين
افغانستان وايران ان هو يروح يقعد في
ايران تحت الاقامه الجبريه ولكن ايضا
للاسف الشديد برضو استطاع ان هو يخطط لبعض
العمليات الارهابيه في الشقيقه السعوديه
اللي هي تفجيرات الرياض طبعا تحت الضغط
السعودي والامريكي
صدرت توجيهات وتعليمات للسلطات الايرانيه
بوضعه تحت الاقامه الجابريه يعني الا
يمارس اي نشاط التي تضر بامن وسلامه الدول
الجوار
كشف تورط صيف العدل بتفجيرات الرياض ساده
اللواء هل يعني الجانب المصري التقت
مكالمات او معلومات من شخصيات اخرى لابد
من الاشاده بالتعاون الامني المصري
السعودي في رصد العناصر المتطرفه او
الارهابيه او عناصر تنظيم القاعده
الموجوده في المنطقه فدي تحسب زي ما قلنا
للتعاون الكبير بين الجانبين ومن هذا
المنطلق فكان رصد فعلا ان هو احد مخطيتي
تكبيرات الرياض هذا الرصد كان موجود وكان
تم اختيار جانب السعودي يعني وعشان كده
السعوديه تواصلت مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وممارسه ضغوطا سياسيه على ايران
لتحجيبه او لوضع تحت الايجار الاقامه
الجبريه وفعلا فضل موجود
طوال هذه الفتره حتى 2015 تحت الاقامه
الجبريه في ايران ولكن ايضا في هذه الفتره
كان يمارس برضو بعض الاعمال الخاصه
بالتدريب يعني بس ما كانش بيمارس اي عمل
تخطيط او كذا او كذا لكن كان برضو بينظم
كان
بيعمل في مجال اعاده الهيكله وخصوصا ان
التنظيم بعد وفاه بن لادن اصابه الوهب
واصاب انت شرزم والتفتت فكان بيلعب دور
كبير في اعاده صياغه تنظيم القاعده في
المنطقه العربيه وخاصه في منطقه افريقيا
يعني في الغرب الاف بالذات كان بيلعب دور
كبير في هذا الاطار
السادس ومن خلال اعترافات من تم القبض
عليهم من قيادات الصف الاول في تنظيم
القاعده بعد تفجيرات كينيا وتنزانيا
فكانت على ان سيف العدل في محطه السودان
كانت بدايه علاقه اسامه بن لادن وتنظيم
القاعده بايران من السودان وانه سيف العدل
تدرب في معسكرات حزب الله اللبناني
ويعني واشرف على هالموضوع هذا عماد مغنيه
هل لدى الجهاز الامن المصري هذه المعلومات
او تفاصيل عنها
حول الجزئيه دي لكن اقدر اقول انه
الحرس الثوري الايراني
كان في فتره وجود
سيف العدل في ايران كان مقيم تحت السيطره
الكامله للحرس الثوري الايراني اللي
بيعتبر حزب الله احد رو بس ما في من خلال
ما تم يعني ضبطهم من قيادات في مصر من
اعطى معلومات على يعني انا بدي اعرف طبيعه
العلاقه اللي ربطت تنظيم القاعده
يعني من خلال معلومات وليس
انه في ثلاثه الكنيه بتاعتهم
يعني ده احدهم صلاح العدل
ومن هذا المنطلق يعني فيهم مثلا واحد اسمه
مصطفى ابن اليزيد ده كان برضو من ضمن
المجموعه اللي كانت كني
طيب ابغى اسالك ساده اللواء
سيف العدل كانت انه يطلق سيف العدل على
ثلاثه شخصيات
وجلس لفتره طويله كان يعتقد من قبل
المخابرات الامريكيه بانه هو سيف العادل
مقصود هو محمد مكاوي
وظلت صوره محمد مكاوي في ضمن
يعني
موقع او الاصدارات الامنيه
للجهات المكافحه الارهاب الامريكيه
تضع صورتك ضمن المطلوبين امنيا في هذا
القائمه قائمه المطلوبين امنيا
ودي تحكي لي هذه الاشاره منذ متى واجهزه
الامن المصريه تعرف هويه سيف العدوى لماذا
جلس لفتره طويله لم تتغير صورتهم
زي ما قلت لحضرتك ليس كل ما يقال يصدق
يعني بمعنى ان هم فعلا كانوا حاطين صوره
مكاوي على اساس ان هو سيف العدل اللي هو
بتاع
صلاح ديدان والحقيقه يعني يحسب للاجهزه
الامنيه انها كانت رافضه هذا الموضوع من
بدايته
فمن هذا المنطلق يعني بنقول دائما ان رصد
العناصر دي من قبل الدول الجوار ومن خلال
معلومات موثقه بتدي مصداقيه اكتر
للمعلومه لصدق المعلومه يعني وفي هذا
المنطلق فبقول انه لا يعني السلطات
الامريكيه واستخبارات الامريكيه كانت حاطه
الصوره دي بطريق الخطا الى ان تم استدراك
هذا الخطا مؤخرا كان يعني هل كانت الاجهزه
الامنيه الاجهزه الامن المصريه كان لديها
معلومه من هو هل تبادلتم المعلومات
لانه هو عنصر ارهابي وعنصر خطر وبالتالي
التعاون الامني زي ما قلنا او التعامل
المختلفه بيوصل الى نقول ايه حلقات
مترابطه ومتكامله ومتمازجه مع بعض هم
عندهم معلومه هنا عندنا معلومه مثلا
المملكه عندها معلوم وهكذا
فلما يحصل تنسيق بين الاجهزه دي بالذات
الحقيقه كامله وبيساعد ده على اتخاذ
القرار او على الاقل على تحديد الشخص او
الاشخاص المطلوبين متى كان تم يعني تعديل
هذه المعلومه هل عندما عاد محمد مكاوي
وجاء الى القاهره في فتره الربيع العربي
تم يعني وهو الذي قال بانه ليس هو سيف
العدل المقصود اثناء عودته وقال هذا
للاجهزه الامنيه المصريه امكان قبلها
بيعيش حياه عاديه جدا
نستطيع ان نقول ان هو خرج من دائره العمل
نقول الارهابي الفاعل في السن يعني
وبالتالي بنقول انه
يعني اللي ظهر في الصوره فعلا زي ما حضرتك
تفضلتي وقلت في بدايه اللقاء ان اللي ظاهر
في الصوره في الوقت الحالي اللي هو يعني
ممكن نقول ان هو مازال
يتعامل او يمارس العمل التدريبي والعسكري
والهيكلي هو صلاح بدير لكن محمد مكاوي
مجرد ما استقر وقعد الانسان الباكستانيه
اعتقد انه يعمل في مجال
[موسيقى]
صلاح الدين اللي هو الجنرال اليوم نجم
تنظيم القاعده اليوم ده ده زي متجوز
من جريمه او من بنت يعني
المجالة محمد المصري يعني ابو الوليد
هو عايش معها في ايران وله منها اربع
اولاد
وعايش حياه يعني يعني انا شفت بعض الصور
لمؤخرا مع اني يعني الصور دي نادره لكن
[موسيقى]
اللي يشوفه يعني يحس ان هو عايش
انسان بسيط الانسان بيمارس حياته العاديه
مش مثلا مش بيلبس جلباب زي زي الافغاني
بنشوفهم لا هذا لابس عادي لبس كاجوال
فيعني اعيش الحياه اللي هي متديش ايحاء ان
هو بيمارس زي ما قلنا عمل تنظيمي او عمل
ارهابي او عمل تنظيمي في في القاعده في
الوقت الحالي هو متزوج بالسيده وحده ولا
اكثر من سيده المعلومه اللي عندنا ده
متزوج من سيده واحده وله منها اربع اولاد
بالنسبه لولده
بمدني المعروف ابن المدني بدات يعني كتبت
تقارير صحفيه عن دور الابن سيف العدل هذا
هل هناك معلومات حول
عن ابن سيف العدل نفسه
انه يلعب دور في داخل سوريا
كموفد من قبل والده لتنظيم القاعده عذرا
يلعب دور في داخل اليمن مفرد من قبل سيف
العدل للعب يعني بوساطه ما بين مركز
القاعده مركز القاعده الام وما بين فرعها
في اليمن
في لا ما عنديش برضو المعلومه الكافيه
يعني من الداخل للداخل او من الخارج
وبالتالي يعني يصعب ان احنا نرصد حاجه ان
انا شخصيا يعني يكون عندي معلومه في هذا
الاطار امم طب ساعه الامتى بدا يتكشف
للامن المصري
العلاقه التي تجمع ما بين مثلا جماعه
الجماعه الاسلاميه المصريه جماعه الجهاد
المصريه مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
بتجمع كل اطياف التنظيمات وكل اطياف في
الاذكار اللي بنقول عليها المتصرفه احنا
هنلاقي في ايران هنلاقي عندهم جماعه
هنلاقي عندهم جماعه الاخوان هنلاقي عندهم
جماعه النصره هنلاقي عنده فهي يعني
الحقيقه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
بتجمع الاطياف دي عندها ممكن يكونوا
شخصيات عاديه ممكن يكونوا شخصيات قياديه
طب ليه بتعمل كده لانه بيعتبروا ان دي
ممكن جدا
تمثل احدى وسائل الضغط على دول الجوار او
الدول
ومن هذا المنطلق هو ساعات اللواء يعني
واضح انه شو الدوري الايراني اللي ترتجيه
مثل هذه العلاقه
البراجماتيه مع تنظيم القاعده وممكن تكون
هي علاقه استراتيجيه ايضا مع تنظيم ولكن
انا ابغى من حيث الجهاز الامني في مصر
قبل كده كان في تنظيم الجهاد الاسلامي ده
من اكثر التنظيمات التصاقا وارتباطا
بالجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه تنظيم
الجهاد وايضا تنظيم الجهاز الفلسطيني اللي
هو كان بيرقصه الفلسطيني فتح الشفاطي ده
برضو من ضمن التنظيمات اللي كانت مرتبطه
ارتباط كبير جدا
بايران يعني اعتقد او اعتبر ان اكثر
فاصلين مرتبطين بايران في الوقت الحالي
اللي هو جماعه الجهاد وجماعه وتنظيم
القاعده في الوقت الحالي انا التقيت سابقا
سعاده اللواء بعناصر كانت سابقه في تنظ
الجهاد المصري وهم بياكد ان احنا ما لنا
علاقه لان عندنا بعد عقدي في موضوع
التعاون مع النظام الايراني لكن الجماعه
الاسلاميه المصريه هي من فتحت الباب
وتعاونت مع النظام الايراني فالى اين الى
اي مدى هذا دقيق
الموجود في ايران فتره طويله
طه رفاعي ده كان احد القيادات الجماعه
الاسلاميه ده كان موجود فعلا قعد فتره في
في ايران
[موسيقى]
وتواجد بعد ذلك او تواصل بعد ذلك بعد
التنظيمات الاخرى لكن انا يعني من خلال
معلوماتي انه برضو بعض يعني بدايتها كانت
الجماعه الاسلاميه ثم بعد كده حصل بعد
اغتيال طبعا الرئيس الراحل انور السادات
يعني ايران استضافه العديد من قيادات
الجماعه الاسلاميه ثم بعد ذلك توالت
القيادات الجماعات الاخرى
وزي ما قلت لحضرتك يعني انا اعلم جيدا
تنظيم الجهاز الفلسطيني من التنظيمات
اللطيفه الوثيقه الصله باجهزه الاستخبارات
الايرانيه يعني يتم ذكره في عدد من
المصادر بان ان البدايه الاولى المجموعات
الجهاد وعلاقتها بايران هي زياره اجراها
القيادي الجهاد القيادي في الجهاد المصري
هو محمد احمد الصاوي
لايران وكشفت اجهزه الامن وقتها عن هذه
القضيه باعاده تشكيل تنظيم الجهاد اللي
كان في هذه القضيه سيف العدل نفسها اللفت
انتباهي بان ان الصاوي طبعا كان معاه
شخصيات اخرى
اسامه
حميد الشهيب اسامه جغرافيا واحمد راشد
محمد راشد كنا سبق استضفناه معنا
الجامعات في احدى الحلقات وهو قياده سابق
في التائب تنظيم القاعده ان هذه القيادات
تم القبض في هذه القضيه على قيادات في
الجيش المصري مثل الضابط محمد البرم ومحمد
صلاح الدين زيدان
والعقيد محمد مكاوي الى ان اعترافات
الصاوي اعترافات الصاوي في القضيه جاءت
تحمل معلومات حيث تم ضبط دراسه مع الصاوي
بعنوان الثوره الايرانيه وظروفها شارك
فيها شخصيات جهاديه فلسطينيه وتركيه
وسوريه
طلع طبعا بحسب اوراق التحقيقات اطلع عليها
قيادات منهم حسن هلاوي عصام مطير وايمن
الظواهري طبعا احنا نتكلم في سنه 87 فهل
هل تذكر لي بعض المعلومات عن هذه خاصه
احنا نتكلم عن القضيه هي نفسها سيف العادل
كان ضمنها
احنا اتفقنا انه سنه 1987 كان هناك
محاولات
تنظيم الجهاز وهذا محاولات تم رصدها بدقه
من اجهزه الامن المصريه ولكن زي ما قلنا
وكان العدد يعني يعني كبير ولذلك
المحاكمات الحقيقه شملت الاسامي اللي
حضرتك تفضلتي فيها دي بالاضافه الى اسماء
اخرى احنا يعني ما نعرفهاش حتى الان لكن
بعد كده لما حصلت موضوع الافرادات سنه
1989 البعض منهم سافر الى
افغانستان تحديدا يعني كان معظم الوجهات
بتاعتهم الى الافراد الاراضي الافغانيه
ولا باكستان وبعض الاخر الى السودان
فعايز اقول انه في السنتين دول اللي هم من
87 ل 89
نجحت الاجهزه الامنيه المصريه في رصد
تقريبا جميع عناصر التنظيم وجهضته ويعني
انا شايف انه التنظيم في الوقت الحالي لا
يمثل خطوره على المنطقه واص بح يعني بلا
مخالب زي ما بيقولوا يعني اصبح النهارده
غير مؤثر على امن المنطقه يعني لان
الصراعات اللي موجوده في المنطقه ما بقتش
ما بين الجهاز او الجماعه الاسلاميه ولكن
بدات تبقى بين تنظيم القاعده وتنظيم داعش
زي اللي انا شايفه دلوقتي احنا ردينا يعني
بالنسبه
علاقه سيف العدل باي بين الظواهري هل هناك
معلومات عن طبيعه العلاقه بينهم هل هي على
وفاق ام ان هناك تنافس ام ان يعني مبالغات
بموضوع الخصومه فيما بين الشخصيات الحياه
انه ايمن الظواهر لم يكن قائد مؤثر بالشكل
اللي كان عليه اسامه بن لادن ومن هذا
المنطلق فكانت فتره
سيطرته او قيادته لتنظيم القاعده ما كانتش
من الفترات اللي فيها نوع من انواع
العنف او العمليات الارهابيه كان كل يعني
الهدف اللي هو الاختفاء والاختباء من
المطاردات الامنيه من هذا المطلق بدا ظهور
العبد يعني دائما
الانسان القوي دائما يظهر في فتره القائد
الضعيف
كان ايمن الظواهر الح
بدايه
المرض وهدايه
احساسه بعدم القدره على اداء مهامه كقائد
لتنظيم القاعده دي كانت بدايه
ظهور بقى قوه سيف العهد وسيطرته على
بعض المحافظات او بعض الاماكن اللي
بيتواجد فيها وده كان تقريبا في سنه 2020
في 20/22
لما قتل ايمن الظواهري بدا يتردد اسم سيف
العبد بشكل اللي احنا بقى دلوقتي بنتناقش
فيه او بالشكل اللي احنا بنتكلم فيه
دلوقتي هل فعلا هذا الرجل اللي كان بيدي
دورات عسكريه والراجل اللي كان له بائع في
توحيد كلمه تنظيم القاعده في بعض الدول
الافريقيه والشخص اللي هو عنده الخبره
العسكريه بعد زي ما قلنا اعتزال مكاوي هذا
العمل فيه واست واستقرار الباكستاني هل
هذا الشخص يصلح ان هو يكون خليفه لايمن
الظاهري ولا لا فكانت علاقته بايمن
الظواهري علاقه الى حد كبير طيبه لكن
علاقته كانت بسبب اللازم مش طيبه وكان
هناك العديد من القيادات التاريخيه كانت
بتنادي باستبعاده من بين التنظيم وزي ما
قلنا انه الشخص اللي احنا بنتكلم عنه ده
مش من الشخصيات التاريخيه التي ساهمت في
تاسيس تنظيم القاعده ان هو بدايته كان
تنظيم الجهاد فعشان كده مش لاقي بول مكنش
لاقي بول وما زال حتى الان برده مش لاقي
قبول من القيادات التاريخيه الموجوده خارج
ايران والمتواجده في افغانستان وفي
باكستان وفي اليمن وفي الصومال
عشان كده بنقول انه
يعني حته ان هو يتولى او لا يتولى انا
شايف تقدير الشخصي ان هي ما زالت محل نقاش
او محل خلاف او محل تبادل وجهات نظر لان
في يمكن شخصيات اقدم منه ما فيش لها قبول
اكتر منه وفي شخصيه ايضا مسيطره على بعض
الاماكن الجغرافيه زي اللي هو
اللي هو
الطريفي ده اللي هو مسيطر على منطقه
الجزيره العربيه ده الحقيقه من وجهه نظري
برضو من الشخصيات التاريخيه اللي احنا
نعتقد ان احنا نكون من اكتر الشخصيات اللي
ممكن يكون منافس
لسيف العدل في قياده تنظيم القاعده
بالنسبه لشخصيات نقول المصريه احنا طبعا
نعرف بعد فتره الربيع في شخصيات خرجت الى
سوريا في شخصيه ابو محمد مصري قتل في
طهران
وايضا يعني في شخصيات كثيره سقطت هل اليوم
هناك شخصيات تعتبر مهمه تكون اهم من سيف
العدل
يعني خاصه نتكلم في مركز المركز الام
لتنظيم القاعده سواء في افغانستان او
المنطقه الحدود القبائليه منطقه القبائل
الحدوديه انا شايف ان في بعض الشخصيات زي
ما قلنا لا تقل عن سيف العدل من وجهه نظرك
النظر زي ما قلت القيادي
خالد بطريفي ده المسؤول عن
بطل بالظبط ده مسؤول التنظيم القاعده في
الجزيره العربيه ايضا القيادي ابو عبيده
العنابي وده جزائري ومسؤول عن التنظيم في
منطقه المغرب العربي ايضا القيادي اياد
ابو غالي وده برده احد مسؤولي التنظيم وده
كان اساسا من جبهه نصره الاسلام والمسلمين
انا شايف ان دول لا من وجهه نظري لا يقل
اهميه
وتواجد زي ما قلنا ويمكن قبليه كمان ومحمد
الجولاني ايضا اللي ماسك منطقه اليمن
والعراق ايضا برضه من
القيادات اللي احنا لا يستهمنا
عن تنظيم القاعده يعني ما له علاقه في
تنظيم القاعده هم على خلاف معه اليوم على
خلاف ولكن له دور وله تاثير يعني لم
ينضموا مثلا الى الى تنظيم اخر وما زال
على قوه القاعده ولكن زي ما بنقول وله على
فكره له دور
برضو لا يستهان به خليني اقول لحضرتك حاجه
مهمه دايما نحط في اعتبارنا انه ما فيش
واحد منشق عن تيار ديني متشدد وبنقول ان
هو اصبح معتدل لا يعني انا بقول انه
الاعتدال ده ده موضوع خارج السياق خارج
السياق اللي احنا بنتكلم فيه فاللي خرج من
دائره مثلا تنظيم القاعده اكيد ما زال
لانه احنا بنتكلم في فكر وليس بنتكلم في
دينميه بنتكلم في استراتيجيه بنتكلم في
تنظيم بنتكلم في نوحي التنظيميه فعشان كده
بقول دايما احنا لما بنيجي نواجه هذه
العناصر دائما بتبقى المواجهه الفكريه
اصعب بكثير جدا من المواجهه الامنيه او
العسكريه فدي يعني احنا اتعلمناها ان
دايما كيف تواجه الفكره بالفكره وكيف
تواجه الحجه اتفضل
في فتره الربيع ما تعرف فتره الربيع
العربي جاء عدد من الشخصيات المصريه من
ايران من بينهم محمد شوق الاسلامبولي شقيق
خالد السنبولي وايضا عندنا مصطفى حامد
نفسه جاء الى مصر مع اعتقد مع زوجته
واسرته
وفي اشخاص اخرين ودي تحكي لي عن هذا اذا
حضرتك كنت وقتها وقفت على هذا الموضوع
وكيف كان الترتيب بقدومهم الى ايران
ولماذا عادوا يعني هناك مثلا ابو الوليد
عاد الى ايران من جديد محمد شوقي اسطنبولي
في تركيا اليوم يعيش هناك
ولماذا بقي سيف العدل في ايران خلينا
للفتره اللي هي ثوره اثناء ثوره الربيع
العربي
يعني الفتره السنه اللي حكم فيها الاخوان
مصر الفتره دي هي مشاهده عوده تلك الكوادر
الى
دولها على فكره يعني احنا بنتكلم طبعا على
مصر بنتكلم في شخصيتين دول بالتحديد يعني
لكن من المؤكد ان في بعض الشخصيات
القياديه الاخرى عادت يعني في الى دولها
والشعوب في هذه الدول نفضت تلك العناصر
بعد ما سقطت حكم او جماعه الاخوان في مصر
هم فعلا هم في التوقيت ده
مصر يعني
بمجرد ما بدات بوادر ثوره 30 يونيو 2013
اقول ان هم تمكنوا من الهروب من من مصر
انهم حسوا انهم شخصيات غير مرغوب فيها من
الشعب المصري قبل ما يكون من غير مرغوب
فيها من النظام في مصر طب بالنسبه ليه يا
مصطفى حامد ودي تحكي لي شو المعلومات عنا
وشو طبيعه علاقته هناك مع الحرس الثوري
الايراني
خاصه عنده موقع الكتروني بينشر في
كل مقالات سيف العادل باسم عابر سبيل
ويعني ويتبنى ذات خطاب التنظيم القاعده
يعني معلش يعني في موضوع مصطفى حامد برضو
تبقى تتكلم يعني
قد اكون غير ملمه قوي بدوره ولكن خليني
اقول ان هو من الشخصيات اللي يعني
مش من الشخصيات
الواحد بها اهتمامه لان هو بدا يخش في
موضوع
المواقع الالكترونيه نشر الكتب كذا فاصبح
دوره الحقيقه يعني مش عايز اقول دور
ديناميكي قد ما هو دور استاتيت يعني
بيكتفي بنشر المقالات بيكتفي بعرض الافكار
المتطرفه من خلال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فقط يعني فده معلومات الحقيقه عن هذا
الشخص يعني
هل العنوان الوطني اللي قدمته الولايات
المتحده مؤخرا عن موقع سيف العدل
بحسب رصد الاجهزه الامنيه المصريه هو دقيق
او البيان بتاع الخارجيه الامريكيه لم
يشهد الى ان المعلومات دي جايه من الاجهزه
المصريه
يعني هو بيقول ان هم هم عندهم معلومات
مؤكده ان هو في ايراد دايما واحنا بنتكلم
في الملفات الامنيه دائما بحط احتمال
واثنين وثلاثه لكن النهارده ان انا اجزم
ان هو مثلا موجود في دوله دوله معينه
وليكن اي دوله غير اجراء مثلا يعني حتى لو
النهارده خبر زي ده انتشر هل النهارده
هتتمسك بوجوده ولا هيحصل زي ما حصل قبل
كده
واساب دوله المغرب الاخرى ولذلك انا بتصور
ان هو اه ممكن يكون فعلا موجود في ايران
ممكن ويكون متحجم اه ممكن لكن في نفس
الوقت بلاش اتجاهل طرديه ان هو وخصوصا ان
هو بيرتبط بعلاقات طيبه جدا مع افريقيا او
بعض الدول الافريقيه زي الصومال زي ما
قلنا زي النيجر زي كده برضو نحط في
اعتبارنا ان هو زي ما في نسبه كبيره ان
قصادتها المخابرات الامريكيه ايضا نحط
برضو احتمال ان هو ممكن جدا يكون موجود في
احدى الدول الافريقيه
جهاز المباحث في فتره الربيع 2011 كان
ذكرت التقارير على ان سيف العدل كان يتنقل
من خارج ايران ذهب الى افغانستان وباكستان
وكان يدير بعض المسائل ثم عاد من جديد الى
ايران فكيف تشوف يعني شو الطبيعه
المعلومات من خلال الرصد الاجهزه المصريه
او او اعترافات لقيادات
يعني دايما التحركات بتاعه العناصر اللي
موجوده خارجها بسهوله جدا بتصل الى اليها
يعني سواء بقى من خلال مصادرنا سواء من
خلال معلومات موثقه الى اخره فجميع تحركات
عناصر تنظيم القاعده وايضا حتى كمان عناصر
داعش اللي موجوده حاليا في الخارج كلها
مرصوده
عشان كده بتبقى الامور الى حد ما تحت
السيطره الامنيه ونكاد نكون نعلم تقريبا
هم موجودين فين والساعه كام وبيفكروا في
ايه وبيعملوا ايه عشان كده دايما بقول انه
الاجهزه
العربيه او الاجهزه المصريه
عندها القدره والمقنع اللي هي تستطيع ان
هي ترصد هذه العناصر معلومات الله يسلمك
سعاده اللواء اذا في معلومات في موضوع
تحرك سيف العدل خلال هذه الفتره من 2011
الى 2015 شو المعلومات لدى الجهاز
خارج ايران انا شخصيا في ما عنديش معلومه
موثقه في هذا في هذا الموضوع الاربع سنين
دول ما عنديش معلومه موثقه عنده حركاته
خارج ايران فيها من 20/11/2015 طب بشكل
عام بعيدا عن هذه الفتره
ما لدى الاجهزه الامنيه المصريه للمعلومات
على حركه سيف العدل في مثلا نقول من بعد
احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر تنقلاته دوروا
نشاطه غير بعيدا يعني احنا نعرف البدايه
حقته في السودان بس ودي تعطيني تفاصيل
اكثر عن عن دور هذا الشخص
الحالي انا شايف ان هو بيحاول النهارده
يثبت اركانه في في المناطق اللي هو مسيطر
فيها او اللي هو متواجد زي ما قلت سواء
كان او سواء كان بعض الدول الافريقيه ومن
منطلق علشان يبقى عنده خلفيه
تدعمه اذا
استفتي على اختياره زعيم لتنظيم القاعده
ايضا ما ننساش ان برضو حركه طالبان الفتره
اللي وقعت فيها عملت له ارضيه قويه هناك
ايضا برضو ايران الفتره اللي عملها في
ايران برده ما نستبعدش اطلاقا ان ايران
تمارس الضغط عشان تخيلي بقى النهارده لما
ايران يكون هذا الشخص موجود عندها ويسمى
او يعلن ان هو تنظيم القاعده تتخيل
النهارده تسيطر على تحركات تنظيم القاعده
اللي هو يعتبر من اهم تنظيمات اللي موجوده
في الوقت الحالي
الارهابيه اللي موجوده في الوقت الحالي
على الساحه طيب ساعات حضرتك كنت وقفت على
موضوع
الارتباط او علاقه علاقه نشات ما بين
الحرس الثوري الايراني وجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين خلال حكم الاخوان في مصر
ما مدى هل كان هناك علاقه ايضا ما بين
عناصر او قيادات تنظيم القاعده وجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين من خلال في تلك الفتره
ما لمشتوه امنيا من ملفات وما الى ذلك
يعني احنا عايزين جماعه الاخوان
افتكر ان كان اعلن ان كان في اتصال ما بين
غسل
المغضوب محمد مرسي مع ايمن الظواهري وده
اتصال يعني معلن عنه مش سر ان احنا نقوله
يعني ومن هذا المنطلق بنقول برده انه
تنظيم الاخوان كان مستعد ان هو او كان على
استعداد ان هو يتعاون مع كل تنظيمات اللي
موجوده سواء تنظيم القاعده او تنظيم
الجهاد
او حتى الدواعش كمان عشان يثبت اركان
تواجده في الحكم في مصر هنا والحمد لله
الخطه دي يعني الحمد لله
بالفشل ويعني ما تعددتش
الاضافه لو في معلومات اضافيه تحكي لي
عنها عن اتصال الظواهري بمحمد مرسي اللي
هو كانت تليفوني كان مرسول وكان يعني
بيتكلم فيها عن استعداد
[موسيقى]
الجماعه استقباله استقبال الكوادر
الموجوده وان مصر تفتح وان في عهد جديد
ولا اخره دي كانت كلها الحقيقه امور يعني
الحقيقه الامن المصريه رصدت هذا الاتصال
يعني من السهل ان احنا نجيبه حتى موجود
على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
فزي ما قلنا يا جماعه الاخوان كنت متصور
ان هي
عنصر جاذب لكل عناصر التطرف خارج الدوله
المصريه ومن هذا المنطلق فكانوا بيرحبوا
زي ما حضرتك قلت ان هم يستقبلوا
شوقي محمد شوقي يستقبلوا ناس كثير جدا من
الخارج في اعقاب احداث 2011 يعني لكن
الناس دي لما استشعرت انه حكمها مش هيستقر
ومش هيستمر سرعان ما غادر البلاد قبل ما
يتم القبض عليه من وجهه نظرك لماذا سيف
العادل بقي في ايران ليش ما جاب مع مجموعه
التي قدمت خاصه ان حماه جايه يعني اعتقد
ان ده يرجع الى اولا هو شخص مطلوب طبعا
لانه كل المؤشرات اولا
[موسيقى]
طالب القبض عليه وعامله مكافاه مليون
دولار للقبض عليه وخمسه مليون دولار لمن
يدلي باي بيانات عنه
يعلم جيدا بقوه الامن المصريه ان هو مش زي
دول خالص ان هو لما يجي لازم يتقبض عليه
لانه زي ما قلت كان محرك او احد مفكري
الاعمال التفجيريه او الارهابيه اللي حدثت
في عهده ابان فتره وجوده في السودان وفي
ايران
هل لديك ساعات هو معلومات عن ايش النقاط
اللي اختلف فيها سيف العدل مع اسامه بن
لادن قبل الاحداث 11 سبتمبر ايش كان طبيعه
الكاريزما يعني الشخص بيناتهم كاريزما
العلاقه شخصيه
زي ما قلنا الى العنف الى الغير
شخصيه متسلطه الى حد كبير
يعني ان هو يسمع الراي الراي الاخر لا كان
الراي بتاعه هو المفروض يمشي وطالما هو من
العسكريين او من المؤمنين عسكريا او
تنظيميا فدي كانت الحقيقه امور كانت دايما
محل خلاف مش مع وسبب اللدن فقط ولكن مع
القيادات اللي حوالين اسامه ولكن هذه
الخلافات تفاقمت بعد لان كان اسامه الذي
كان عنده القدره على احتواء هذه المواقف
الاختلافات لكن مع موته اصبح دلوقتي لما
تولى الشخصيه الهاديه الضعيفه
قدره تنظيميه او كذا تفاقمت هذه الخلافات
وده عشان كده انا بقول انه قد يترتب على
هذه الخلافات او الاختلافات ان يكون هناك
اكثر من منافس لي في زعامه تنظيم طب هل
هل تنكر خلال تنقله يعني اذا كان لديك
معلومه في هذا الاطار
والاسماء
الفتره اللي هي كانت موجوده فيها في ايران
اتفقنا وقلنا ان كانت فتره طويله جدا كانت
تحت الاقامه الجبريه فما كانش في مبارز ان
هو يتخسى او يتنقل يعني
قاعدش حاجه
فعشان كده طبعا ولكن ولكن سمه عناصر تنظيم
القاعده التنظيم ارهابي دائما حته التنكر
التخسي استخدام الاسماء مختلفه دي معروف
عنهم كده نظرا لان هم طبعا دائما بيعتبروا
ان الهاجس العلمي عندهم في المقام الاول
وبناء عليه فدائما بيكون عندهم حته
استخدام اساسي اللي هو بالنسبه للاشخاص
اللي من عاد من ايران هل كان هناك يعني
ايران هل منحتهم ايران اسماء اخرى
وهويات اخرى
او جوازات ايرانيه انا ودي بس لو تعطيني
شويه معلومات في الحياه دي برضو والحقيقه
مش مش معلومات عندي ان هو ولكن من المؤكد
ان بعد الفتره الطويله دي اللي هو موجود
فيها خارج مصر اكيد صلاحيه الجواد المصري
انتهت وطبعا اكيد السفارات المصريه مش
هتجدد الباسبور فمن الوارد جدا جدا ان هو
يكون حصل على جوازات سفر اخرى لكن الحقيقه
هي ايه بالظبط الجوازات الاخرى اللي
بيحملها الحقيقه
هذا الموضوع وشخصيه
بيجد دعم من
الدول التي
مكث فيها فترات طويله دي كلها امور
غير ايران من هي الدول غير ايران ممكن
افغانستان السودان دول الدولتين الثابت
فيهم ان هو تنقل فيهم واقام فيهم فترات لا
باس بها يعني لكن الفتره الاطول هي الفتره
التي قضاها في ايران
كلها امور بتجعل بتجعله هو شخصيا مؤهل
نفسيا لمثل هذا المنصب او لمثل هذا
الوضع يعني لكن
خلينا نقول ان التنظيم انا عايز اقول حاجه
يعني في الاخر عايز اقول تنظيم القاعده
ما هواش بنفس القوه والقدره التنظيميه
والقدره التكتيكيه ولا القدره حتى الماليه
اللي اذا استطعت من خلالها ان هو يعمل
عمليات واسعه وعلى مدى وعلى على مستوى
واسع وعلى مستوى دول ما عادش دلوقتي ولذلك
هو النهارده كل اللي بيعمله
بيحاول يلملم
بقايا تنظيم القاعده في الدول اللي المد
الامن فيها او الدولي الامني فيها الى حد
ما مش قوي ودي يعني وجد ضليته زي ما قلنا
في بعض الدول للاسف في الافريقيه ولكن
[موسيقى]
بهذا السؤال حضرتك كنت مسكته احدى
المسؤولياتك الامنيه كانت
بمكتب
مكتب العمل او ما ادري كيف بتسمونا في
سوريا كان لك نشاط هناك
رسمي
هل هل هذا العمل الامني كان يعني ما كشفته
عنا من دور لتنظيم القاعده
الاول بعدما هو كان بيهتم بشؤون المصريين
وعايز اقول ان في هذا التوقيت بالذات كانت
من اكثر التنظيمات اللي موجوده كان تنظيم
من زمان كان اسمه تنظيم التكسير والهجره
دول اللي هو استغلوا فتره العلاقات
المصريه السوريه كانت فتره
من الفترات الايجابيه جدا فكان المصريين
دول بيخشوا هناك من غير تاشيرات دخول فكان
الحقيقه فتره وجودنا هناك كان من الفترات
اللي احنا كنا بنتابع فيها
هذا التنظيم واعتقد ان التنظيم
مفيش حتى المسمى اساسا ما يبقاش موجود
دلوقتي على ساحل التنظيمات الارهابيه هذه
مهمه يعني تنظيم التكفير والهجره هو كان
في سوريا يعني خرجت عناصر الى سوريا خرجت
عناصر من مصر الى سوريا مشتغلين في ذلك زي
ما قلنا عدم المطالبه بتاشيرات الدخول
ولكن زي ما قلنا العناصر دي احنا بنتكلم
على فتره طويله من زمن
1997 يعني كان لسه تنظيمات اللي موجوده
دلوقتي ما ظهرتش حتى على الساحه ده اللي
هو التنظيم بتاع شكري مصطفى
اللي تم اعدامه
يعني لكن بعيد
الناس العناصر كانت عناصر نقول ما هياش
مؤثره على الساحه وزي ما قلت بردو كان حصل
بعد كده عمليه
وكلهم تراجعوا عن افكارهم دي الحقيقه
بالحوار
تعتبر من التنظيمات او من الايجابيات اللي
برضو الامن المصري ان هو استطاع ان هو
يكون حاجات المراجعات الفكريه دي برضه
الحقيقه نجحنا فيها الى حد كبير وخصوصا مع
الجماعه الاسلاميه وقبليها جماعه
ويعطيك الف عافيه وشكرا لك مشاركتنا بهذه
المعلومات واسمح لي ان اختم هنا على
الارجح ان قصه سيف العادل وعنوانه الوطني
ستظل معنا فتره من الزمن ليست بالقصيره
هذا جماعه اطوانه هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]